للمتابعه معنا من بيروت الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه العميد الياس حنا اهلا بك
عميد حنا اذا ما زال هناك تبادل
الالتهامات حول الهجوم على هذا السد لكن
حتى الان بناء على التداعيات حتى الان من
يبدو المستفيد من هذا التفجير
سهام هناك الفريقان خاسران حتى الان بالحد
الادنى بالحد الادنى اوكرانيا ولكن
المستفيد الاكبر من ضمن مبدا
الضرورات تبيح المحظورات انه اذا كان هناك
فعلا من هجوم يحضر جبهه خرسون لم تكن
الجبهه الرئيسيه لان عبور النهر قبل
التفجير السد هو ايضا عائق امام القوات
الاوكرانيه وليس هناك من عمليه
عبور كبيره يمكن انجازها ولكنها كانت تشكل
احد فكي الكماشه هذا الامر يؤخر العمليه
يعني مرحله ما قبل تفجير السد العمليه
العسكريه شيء ومرحله ما بعد يلزمها اعاده
التقييم والتحضير للتعويض في مكان ما
اثنين من هو قادر على التفجير من هو يسيطر
هذا امر مهم جدا يعني هذا الجسر هذا السد
كان منذ سنه واكثر تحت السيط الروسيه حتى
ان هذا
السد عندما يبنى مضاد للزلازل اذا صح
التعبير او للتفجيرات وحتى لحرب النوويه
في مكان ما لا يمكن ان يكون هناك قصف من
بعيد حتى ولكن حكما قيل استار شادو 250
كيلو جرام الراس الحربي يمكن تدميره هو
ليس
مستحيلا ولكنه بعيد الاحتمال في هذه
الحاله وبالتالي تعتقد ان تفجير السد
سيساعد في تحقيق تقدم ما باتجاه خرسون
هذا الامر عثمان خلق اليوم حاجز طبيعي
يعني اليوم هذا الامر يستلزم اربعه ايام
كي تعود المياه الى مجاريها ولكن
الاضرار الناجمه عن حفتين نهر هي مفيده
للجيش الروسي لانه اصلا بنى تحصينات وحفر
ومضاده للدبابات وما شابه في هذه المنطقه
في جنوب نهر خرسان قد يحرر بعض القوى
للذهاب الى المركز الجهد الاساسي الذي يتم
الحديث عنه ذا فروتوب ماك وبالتالي الى
بحر ازوف قد يكون تحرير هذا الامر وهو في
الحد الادنى يكسب وقت ويؤخر الهجوم
الاوكراني لانه بالحد الادنى وبالعقل
العسكري على الاوكرانيين ان يعيدوا ترتيب
وضعهم والتاقلم مع الواقع الجديد عسكريا
عندما تقول ان روسيا مبدئيا هي المستفيده
ربما من هذا التفجير باعتبار انها قد
تعرقل تقدم القوات الاوكرانيه ضمن ما يعرف
بالهجوم المرتقب المضاد وايضا لانها تسيطر
على المنطقه هل يعني ذلك ان عرقل التقدم
القوات الاوكرانيه اولويه بالنسبه لها
مقارنه مع امداد شبه جزيره القرن بالمياه
والذي نعلم انه سيتضرر الان مع هذا
التفجير
سهام منذ عام 2014 حتى العام 22 ثمانيه
سنوات لم يكن هناك ماء من هذه من هذه
القناه طولها 420 كيلو متر وما شابه 81 او
85% منها للزراعه وخمس المياه للشرب اليوم
اهميتها من هنا قلت انا الضرورات تبيح
المحظورات هذا الامر يختلف تماما في الجهد
العسكري لو تاملنا العكس ان القوات
الاوكرانيه استردت جزيره القرم والمياه
تتدفق اليها هذا الامر قد يضرب فكره
واستراتيجيه الرئيس بوتين الكبرى لانه
تعتبر شبه جزيره القرم هي
الجوهره في التاج في المشروع الروسي اليوم
هذا الامر يختلف تماما يوم نتحدث عن صراع
عسكري صراع جيو سياسي لهم امتداد ضمن
اوكرانيا باوروبا وحتى على العالم من هنا
هذا هذه المخاطره
شكرا لك الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
العميد الياس حنا كنت معنا من بيروت